si ma furie ma colère ma peine ne
transparaisse pas sachez qu'elles sont
en créant moi il n'y aura aucune
impunité aucune les responsables de
cette situation trouvons toujours ce
Parlement du côté de la loi la
corruption ne peut pas payer elle était
inconnue sur la scène politique
internationale la voici au cœur du plus
grand scandale touchant une institution
européenne et vacailly vice-présidente
du Parlement dort désormais en prison
ils sont inculpés pour appartenance à
une organisation criminelle blanchiment
d'argent et corruption selon une source
proche du dossier Eva Kelly a été prise
en flagrant déliéna donc pas pu
bénéficier de son immunité parlementaire
qui est du lobbying c'est une chose qui
est d'un côté des menaces de l'autre des
tentatives de corruption là c'est tout à
fait autre chose c'est une tentative
d'acheter nos démocraties et ça c'est
pas acceptable une corruption qui aurait
eu pour objet de tenter de modifier des
décisions politiques ou économiques du
Parlement européen trois autres
personnes ont aussi été
dont cet ancien député italien toujours
très influent au total plusieurs
centaines de milliers d'euros ont été
saisis chez eux l'Union européenne
depuis maintenant plusieurs années série
Jean modèle de vertu et donne des leçons
de morale et des leçons droits de
l'homme à la terre entière on s'aperçoit
aujourd'hui qu'elle est présumée
corrompue jusqu'à son plus haut niveau
c'est pas la première fois d'ailleurs et
pour moi c'est révélations ne sont pas
très étonnantes c'est une pratique qui
est assez courante qui est ancienne
cette capacité d'acheter de l'influence
mais en général les circuits sont assez
bien rodés et ce qui est très difficile
c'est d'établir justement la preuve de
la corruption et celle-là je l'ai
imprimé donc en novembre je reçois cette
invitation moi je travaille sur les
questions d'emplois et d'affaires
sociales c'est mes sujets et donc je
reçois cette invitation d'une ONG qui
s'appelle démocratie Center Ford
transparenti donc centre de la
démocratie pour la transparence et donc
je suis invitée à une mission au Qatar
où on propose d'aller regarder comment
et bien les droits humains sont
respectés et notamment les droits le
droit du travail les droits des
travailleurs sont respectés on avait
révélé avec George malonneau donc
attraperce comment les katariens avaient
beaucoup financé en France l'islam les
mosquées les centres islamiques donc ça
Macron il a pas aimé il y a l'alliance
avec la Turquie il a pas aimé non plus
dans la forêt Samuel Paty pareil il y a
eu des campagnes de boycott au Qatar des
produits français en général c'est quand
même ça devient quand même d'en haut
c'était pas plus tard que la semaine
dernière à Bruxelles j'imagine pas avoir
été la seule mais on reçoit une
invitation à aller dans un des hôtels
les plus luxueux de Bruxelles pour et
bien participer à une réception
organisée par l'ambassade du Qatar il
faut démocratiser la France insoumise
les mots de clémentine au thym écartés
de la nouvelle direction du parti la
députée de Seine-Saint-Denis réclame
davantage de délibération collective et
de pluralisme une prise de position qui
a immédiatement fait réagir Jean-Luc
Mélenchon sur Facebook
toute la une pour nous salir la raison
de la colère de Clémentine Autain la
voici la nouvelle coordination du
mouvement elle mais aussi Alexis
Corbière Eric Coquerel n'en font pas
partie tout comme François Ruffin
également très remonté j'entends que ça
s'est fait au consensus ça c'est fait au
consensus d'un petit groupe qui est
peut-être s'est mis d'accord avec
lui-même c'est vrai que si on peut
éviter de détaler ces discussions sur la
place publique c'est mieux il n'y a bien
évidemment aucune volonté d'exclusion ou
de ou de mettre qui que ce soit de côté
si vous voulez mon problème aujourd'hui
c'est pas Clémentine autant François
Ruffin mon problème c'est Emmanuel
Macron nous avons tout ce qui est une
réforme des retraites qui a fait l'objet
de beaucoup de discussions concertation
ces dernières semaines des derniers mois
n'était apparu pertinents de décaler de
quelques jours ou quelques petites
semaines
l'annonce de la finalisation de la
proposition du gouvernement la réforme
qui devait initialement être présenté ce
jeudi 15 décembre est ainsi décalé au 10
janvier c'est uniquement pour enjamber
les fêtes de Noël et éviter que ce soit
le sujet principal de discussion autour
de la dinde bon voilà c'est habile
peut-être tactiquement mais c'est pas la
hauteur de l'enjeu c'est une annonce qui
en creux marque une sorte de petit recul
sur sa réforme des retraites dont il
sait qu'elle est grandement impopulaire
dans le pays on peut
ouvrir au pire se dire que le Président
nous prend un peu pour des biens